meaning let's take a moment to make
sense of meaning or at least see how
other people do what kinds of things
means something words we usually think
those mean something
signs sure I'll give you that one
body language okay buildings I don't
know about that one rocks again I don't
really know about that let's just focus
on these things the ones were
comfortable saying means something what
do they have in common as far as their
meaning goes they all have some on the
surface symbolic feature something that
they are like a painted sign with a
specific pattern a sequence of letters
an arm with fingers held in a certain
way but we also take them all to stand
for something else meaning is what makes
this possible to use the traditional
term we could call all of these signs
then we'd say that all of these signs
stand for something and recall this
relationship meaning in linguistics
semantics hashes out this relationship
between words and phrases and their
meanings some quirks come up when you
look at meaning and language one major
one is fuzzyness words don't necessarily
have fixed independent meanings think of
words like pizza cheese sauce bread we
don't take these to mean the same thing
but they all depend on each other in a
way and each one encompasses a different
range of things for different people and
different cuisines the form of a word
and the meaning of a word don't match or
parallel each other the relationship
between them is mostly arbitrary there's
nothing about the sound or shape of the
English word cheese or for that matter
the Italian word for ma Joad that
inevitably link them to this meaning
meaning changes over time the old
English word Sally meant fortunate but
that word now pronounced silly means
something quite different if you're
interested in meaning and the etymology
of words here's a video with more on
meaning change also context really
matters for meaning in language and
ambiguity lingers around many corners if
I tell you he turned red you can imagine
a few possibilities this kind of issue
brings the actions surrounding any bit
of language to our attention linguists
have a term for this context that feeds
the meaning of any piece of language
pragmatics that's the fancy term for the
context sensitivity of meaning context
isn't just important for recognizing the
meaning of words the phases people make
the tone somebody uses touch or body
movement all communicates something
about meaning subtler features even come
into play like how far how close
somebody is standing to you which in the
1960s one anthropologist termed
proxemics escaping beyond immediate
interactions with other humans we also
think that physical signs and symbols
have meanings I already admitted as much
about this particular sign earlier
gathering up all the different
meaningful signs and studying how they
work is the business of semiotics
semantics in language semiotics and
signs in general but enough of this
name-dropping meaning matters in logic
too but here it's not so much about how
context and communication impact meaning
but about the role meaning plays in
reasoning arguing and thinking I can
take thoughts like she likes tofu and he
likes ice cream
she likes ice cream and he likes tofu
she likes ice cream and he likes ice
cream and I can reduce them to a common
pattern x and y that pattern is the
logical form
we see in all three sentences now the
three of them don't mean the same thing
once we assign meanings to that bit of
logic x and y we get three sentences and
we can tell if they're right or not of
course we do need to define some of the
words who is he who is she what exactly
counts as tofu how would we know that
they like it here the focus is on
defining words clarifying meaning and
avoiding pitfalls like using vague
language to arrive at a false conclusion
as long as I'm asking questions here are
some more general ones looking at the
images from before I thought of these
ones as meaningful is that a property
they have outside of my head is the
meaning just inside my head what's the
role of my psychology in determining
meaning similarly our meanings tied to
real things in the world around us are
they just tied to ideas in our minds is
the meaning part of our thoughts a
separate component like logic suggests
somehow different from the structure of
our thoughts do the best dictionaries
tell us what words actually mean or do
they merely document how words are being
used what about common sense the feeling
of shared meaning across a group of
people does it have any role in meaning
do meanings exist if so where what are
they made of for things to mean does
meaning itself have to mean if so how
does it these and other deceptively
simple questions get us thinking about
the issues that the philosophy of
language takes up when it comes to
meaning while we can keep going meaning
matters in a variety of subjects and
studies but I just wanted to leave you
with an idea of how meaning is
approached to complement my other videos
in linguistics and logic and language
learning as always thanks for learning
with me
you